Commodities issues dire climate change
warning in Africa
existential threat to the entire planet
okay she said this three days ago I want
to say April 1st
vice president Kamala Harris visits
panuka Farm in Zambia Zambia and gave
Stern warning about the existential
threat of climate change calling it a
global priority Harris noted that Africa
has won the lowest uh emitters of
greenhouse gases but is playing some of
the highest cost related to climate
change particularly in terms of food
security Harris highlighted the
importance of climate resilient
Agriculture and reducing greenhouse gas
emissions around the world citing food
scarcity as a cause of conflict and
displacement Harris's visit to Africa as
part of the Biden's Administration
efforts to build partnership and bolster
the content continence growth amid the
global rivalry over its resources what's
your thoughts about the story with Kamal
Harris well as it's it's you know very
typical of almost all Western
politicians will go down and lecture uh
poor Africans uh on climate change and I
think it tells you two things first of
all she wants to say this is an
existential threat and it goes back to
that whole conversation we had before
that most people who are advocating on
climate will tell you this is the end of
the world and it's obvious because if
you can get people to believe this is
the end of the world you don't think
about the cost so it's a little bit like
with covet if you know if we don't do
all these Draconian things we're all
going to die then you're more willing to
let yourself do that it is not climate
change is a problem not the end of the
world and that should it be helpful if
you actually told the truth on that the
second bit is much more Sinister I think
because that goes to saying I'm here in
Africa and a lot of people will
typically say you are so vulnerable to
climate change so that makes it the most
important thing we should all cut our
carbon emissions well why are they
honorable because they are poor remember
yes poor people are most vulnerable to
climate but they're also most vulnerable
to pretty much everything else they're
vulnerable to not having enough food to
not having good health not having good
schooling all these other things so why
not Target economy why why go climate
instead of economy if you actually want
to make poor people less vulnerable also
to climate but presumably also to all
these other things you lift them out of
poverty it's not rocket science and they
know that themselves so what Uganda and
others are actually saying is we would
like to get rich as you are Miss Kamala
Harris right they would obviously like
to be like the U.S they would like to
have a lot more energy what are we
telling them where's Helen no we're
saying you cannot start using fossil
fuels I know we're using what 80 90 of
our energy from fossil fuels but no you
can't do that
so Uganda actually wants to increase its
emissions and have much more energy that
would make them much richer which is a
tiny fraction per capita of what the US
would ever do but the US and almost all
other rich countries are saying no we
are literally telling no you have to
stay in poverty in order to fix climate
change I think that's incredibly
entitled and of course the reason why we
do that is because Camilla Harris and
all other Western politicians know that
they can't tell you or me or other rich
people I'm sorry you have to go you know
sit in the cold and dark and and be poor
that's never going to work but they
don't seem to mind to tell that to poor
countries and that's of course why a lot
of African countries don't like us very
much just to give give you a sense of
proportion
average person in Uganda
has less power
than what in total for industry and
everything then the average Californian
use to heat his or her pool
that's the sort of level we're talking
about they use more on heating their
pools than the average
Ugandan has for everything and this of
course is why they actually think and I
think they have some moral right to say
that we'd like some more so why doesn't
Greta go down to uh Africa and interact
with people who have so little why
doesn't she do that
yeah she knows that that would look bad
but it is it is it is impressing that
she goes to the U.S and to America to
Americans and Europeans and tell them
you got a cut but not to Chinese and
Indians and Africans because she knows
that would be looking really bad so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]